[Inaudible].
The sun's core is shrinking,
but as its core shrinks,
the sun itself grows larger and it will continue to
grow until one day it engulfs the
earth. How long can you survive?
What will happen to the oceans.
And will other planets be affected?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if the sun swallowed the earth
every 1 billion years, the sun becomes 10% hotter,
but you're on what if we're going to take billions of years and condense the
action into one month,
get ready because we're going to be moving really fast this time.
Instead of 1 billion years,
it would only take four days for the sun to become 10% hotter.
This means you'll see the earth in Gulf, by the sun in just one month.
That is if you're still around to witness the final.
[Inaudible].
Day one,
you'd be blissfully unaware of the tragedy about to befall earth.
Maybe it's a little hotter, but that's just weather.
It happens.
By day four space agencies across the globe would be sounding the alarm
bells. By this time,
the sun would be about 10% brighter and hotter.
And.
While 10% doesn't sound like a lot,
it will be the beginning of the end for us.
As the sun heats up more and more water from earth surface will
evaporate into the atmosphere.
This will increase the greenhouse gas effect causing global temperatures to
skyrocket.
All of a sudden it will become very humid and very
The sun's high energy light would bombard the atmosphere.
Splitting those water molecules into hydrogen and oxygen.
Earth.
Will begin to lose its water and you won't be able to escape the lethal
radiation on earth surface.
If.
You want to survive, you'll have to go deep, underground.
But.
Even under a protective layer of earth soil, you won't be safe for long
By day 16, the sun would be almost 40%.
Our planet's oceans will boil and there won't be any moisture left in the
atmosphere.
The beautiful.
Lush earth that you grew up on will become a hot dry barren.
Around.
Day 20, the sun would run out of hydrogen.
So instead it will start to burn helium in its core.
The sun is now a red giant star and would expand rapidly
while losing its mass.
The sun's gravitational pull on earth would be weakened and our planet
would begin to drift away from the expanding sun,
but not far enough.
According.
To researchers, Klaus, Peter Schroeder and Robert C. Smith,
the earth would only have moved about
0.0002. Astronomical units.
An astronomical unit is the distance between earth and the sun.
While earth is moving away from the encroaching sun,
the red giant would grow up to 1.2 astronomical units in
radius.
The sun.
Would be larger than Earth's orbit. It would swallow the planet home.
One second.
It's inside the sun's atmosphere.
Earth would collide with particles of gas and spiral inward
and earth.
Wouldn't be the only casualty of the expanding sun mercury and
Venus would be.
The rings of Saturn would melt.
Pluto would become much warmer. And if there.
Is a liquid surface and a thick atmosphere on this distant dwarf planet,
it might even become in-house.
Beautiful.
Unfortunately,
30 days doesn't give the human race enough time to prepare for such a category.
Event.
If we had more time, like billions of years worth,
we could come up with an evacuation plan.
But that's a story for another. What is.